ginny and georgia taylor swift is not
happy with you
so what you and hunter i'm guessing
that's over what do you care you go
through men faster than taylor swift
taylor is taking issue with that jab at
her dating history made on netflix's new
series you never know
what it's going to be on monday the 31
year old singer called out the joke as
deeply sexist and degrading
jesus mom jenny the moment happens in
netflix's latest hit
ginny in georgia the show follows a
young mother and her teenage daughter
the first season debuted last week the
best advice i've ever gotten
was to be kind to people
the t swift dig happens in the season
finale
ellen told me that was fun jesus
so what you and hunter i'm guessing
that's over what do you care you go
through men faster than taylor swift
it took her a few days to respond but
the fearless singer
isn't holding back in expressing her
disappointment
oh good i was waiting for this one to be
all my fault
taylor wrote quote hey ginny and georgia
2010 called and it wants its lazy
deeply sexist joke back how about we
stop degrading hard-working women by
defining this horse
as funny taylor also slammed the
streaming service
adding quote also netflix after miss
americana
this outfit doesn't look cute on you
happy women's history month
i guess nobody physically saw me for a
year
netflix has exclusive rights to miss
americana taylor's intimate documentary
that debuted
just over a year ago and i've been doing
this
for 15 years and i'm tired of it it just
gets
loud sometimes and the controversy
didn't stop there
on social media so what are we doing
tonight swifties were quick to say this
isn't the first time a netflix series
has joked about her love life
pointing to an episode of degrassi next
class which featured this
remark taylor swift made an entire
career off of her exes
e.t has reached out to netflix for
comment